Fish semen injected into your face
so you can have flawless skin like Kim Kardashian,
but you don't have to inject it.
And this was me literally two weeks ago,
and this is me now. If you ask anyone,
they're gonna say PDRN. Now,
PDRN is actually little tiny pieces of DNA
originally pulled out of umbilical cords.
So PDRN actually boosts this cell turnover rate.
More DNA more cell turnover rate,
therefore helping your skin regenerate faster.
Now what they found out is that salmon's heal super fast,
so by taking their PDRN, it accelerates that regeneration,
helping to support getting rid of those fine lines and wrinkles.
Is what most people don't know
is those wrinkles can actually just be dehydration line.
We still got some work to do,
but those wrinkles are actually going away,
which to me is mind blowing,
cause I've always had a really deep wrinkles,
and if that doesn't scream Korean glass skin,
then I don't know what does.
I knew it was one of Korea's top brands,
and in Korea it had people lining out the door at the pharmacy.
So you get rid of the wrinkles,
you hydrate your skin, you repair your skin.
The only problem is they're selling out super quick.
So I'll tell you what, I'll leave a link for you in this video.
Just make sure you get them before they sell out again.